what about terence tao
he's kind of a superstar what are your
thoughts about him true
he's probably one of the most famous
mathematicians alive today
and problem of i mean regardless of like
is of course
he want to feel the fields metal is a
really smart and talented mathematician
um
it's also like a big inspiration for us
uh
um at least for some of the work that we
do with fermat's library
so terence style is is known for having
you know a big
blog and he's pretty open about um like
his research and he
also he tries to make his work as public
as possible um through his blog posts
um in fact there's a really interesting
um
problem that got solved a couple of
years ago so tao was working
with uh on a problem on an air dose
problem actually so if paul erdogan was
this
mathematician from hungary and he was
known for like
um the erdos for a lot of things but one
of the things that it was also known was
for the eredos problem so he was always
like creating these problems and usually
associating prizes with those problems
and a lot of those problems are still
open like and and they will be some of
them will be open for like maybe
a couple hundred years and i think
that's actually an interesting hack
for him to collaborate with future
mathematicians you know his
his name will will keep coming up in you
know for future
generations but so tao was working on
one of these problems called the erdog
discrepancy
and he published a blog post on like
about that pro
about that problem and he reached like a
dead end
and then um all of a sudden there was
this guy
from from germany that wrote like a
comment on his blog post saying
okay like some of the so this problem is
like a sudoku like flavor and some of
the machinery that we're using to solve
the
sudoku could be used here and that was
actually the key to solve their those
discrepancy problems so the there was a
comment on his blog and i think that
that
that for me is an example of like how to
do again going back to collaborative
science online um and the power that it
has
but always is also like pretty public
about
like some of the struggles and of being
a
a mathematician like and and even he
wrote about some of the
unintended consequences of having
extraordinary ability in a field
and he used himself as an example when
he was growing up he was
extremely talented in in mathematics
from a young age like todd was
a person he won an uh medal in like one
of the imo's at the age i think was a
gold medal at the age of 10 or something
like that
and and so he mentioned that when he was
growing up like and especially in
college
when he was in a class that he enjoyed
it didn't it just came
very natural for him and he didn't have
to work hard to just ace the class
and when he found that the class was
boring like it didn't work and he barely
passed
barely passed eve some i think in
college he almost failed two classes
and and he was talking about that and
how he brought those studying habits or
like
uh in existence of studying habits when
he went to prison princeton for his phd
and in for instance when he you know
started kind of
um delving into more complex problems
and classes he struggled a lot because
he didn't have that
those those habits like it wasn't taking
notes and he was
he wasn't studying hard when he when he
faced problems
and he almost failed out of his his phd
uh he almost failed his phd exam
and um it it talks about like having
this conversation with with his advisor
and the advisor pointing out like
you're not this is not working you might
have to get out of the program
and like how that was a kind of a
turning point for him
and um and like it was super important
in his career so
i think tao is also like this figure
that apart from being just
an exceptional mathematician is also
pretty open about you know what what it
takes to to to be a mathematician and
some of the struggles
of these type of careers and and i think
it's that's super important
in many ways he's a contributor to open
science and open
humanity so he's he's being an open
human
right through by communicating uh scott
aaron says another in computer science
world who's a
very different style very different
style but there's something about a blog
that um
is authentic and real and just gives us
a window into the
into the mind and soul of of all of
these brilliant folks so
it's it's definitely a gift
you